given a string of failures and
criticisms Disney could be heading
toward an unprecedented era in their
Marvel franchise but could they have one
last trick up their sleeve Marvel
Studios is in an extremely unfamiliar
situation right now after the $2 billion
success that was Avengers endgame the
company was humming with excitement as
it looked toward the future with the
Advent of Disney plus the studio began
to diversify its offerings debuting
projects like one Division and the
Falcon and the Winter Soldier to
populate the streaming service they
began digging deep into the archives
greenlighting films based on lesser
known properties like eternals and
chongqi but Marvel's luck seems to have
run out as its offerings are receiving
unprecedented criticism from poor CGI to
inconsequential storytelling Marvel is
no longer the Juggernaut it used to be
in the eyes of the public and interest
appears to be waning according to
variety sources say Marvel and Disney
might be interested in making a major
consequential decision in the report
which highlights Marvel caus various
woes and existential worries the outlet
notes that the studio may be interested
in resurrecting Iron Man and Black Widow
for a future Avengers movie not a great
plan both Avengers ceremoniously died in
endgame sacrificing their lives to save
Humanity the report also adds that
there's intention to bring the original
gang back for a future Avengers flck
though only Downey Jr and Joe Hansson
are explicitly mentioned seeing as
Marvel's clouds is diminishing bringing
back Downey Jr and Johansson feels like
a break in case of emergency decision
that could diminish the impact of
endgame while nothing is confirmed it's
baffling that Disney and Marvel Studios
are considering bringing back Robert
Downey Jr and Scarlet Johansson not even
5 years after they retired from their
roles in Avengers endgame the deaths of
Iron Man and Black Widow served as the
emotional heart of the 2019 superhero
flick and it'll be interesting to see if
Marvel can convince audiences to jump on
board for their return when it came to
Iron Man's death audien is weren't just
saying goodbye to the character Tony
Stark's sacrifice was a goodbye to
Robert Downey Jr as well
[Music]
hi Iron Man the line was a farewell to
Downey Jr and his decade long
relationship with Marvel Studios while
Scarlet Johansson returned as Black
Widow for a 2021 solo outing that film
served as a prequel giving further
insight into her familiar life since
then black widow's death has become a
key part of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe particularly when it comes to
the Arc of a surate sister Elena belova
if Marval decides to move forward with
the resurrection it will no doubt post
major profit however it's a decision
that would essentially eliminate all
sense of permanence or consequence in
the franchise cementing the fact that
anyone even the most prominent actors in
the series can be brought back from the
dead will Robert Downey Jr and Scarlet
Johansson return as her Avengers
characters anything is possible but the
actors have previously expressed
disinterest in the idea of jumping back
into the MCU when asked by Joe Rogan in
2020 if he'd be willing to return as
Iron Man Downey Jr responded with a
loaded question let me ask you the
question if I pick the Jersey backup and
put it on wouldn't you feel a little bit
like oh crap similarly while appearing
on the goop podcast in 2023 with fellow
Marvel star Gwyneth palro Johansson
discussed how she was done with the
Marvel Cinematic Universe I'm done
you're done I'm done I'm hanging IAP
chapter's over yeah of course Marvel
Studios boss Kevin feige could prove to
be persuasive convincing the two to
return for a future Avengers project the
next film in The Avengers franchise is
set to be 2026 is the Kang Dynasty while
it remains to be seen what that film
looks like considering Kang actor
Jonathan Maes may have his role reduced
in the series after his arrest the
introduction of variant could help bring
gu Man and Black Widow back in comic
books characters are killed and brought
back all the time so it makes sense that
the films would want to take cues from
The Source
[Music]
material